[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrado
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y france
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en las
elecciones que se van a celebrar en
bolivia el próximo 18 de octubre
elecciones en un contexto de pandemia y
de máxima tensión para ello me acompaña
en este estudio tres invitados se les
pasó a saludar verónica calvo politóloga
especialista en bolivia bienvenida
verónica contamos también con sabín
granadown jefa de la selección
latinoamericana del club internacional
bienvenidas a lin wen a ti y contamos
también con mi compañero de france 24
david meza no bienvenido david royo a
los bolivia elecciones en contexto de
pandemia y máxima tensión hoy en primera
plana
[Música]
bueno pues octubre marca el inicio de un
ciclo electoral un año decisivo para
américa latina en el que presidentes y
partidos políticos serán puestos a
prueba en un contexto inédito el de la
pandemia y la crisis económica el
primero en hacerlo va a ser bolivia en
tan solo dos semanas unas elecciones por
cierto que ya fueron pospuestas por la
contingencia del coronavirus las
encuestas dibujan como escenario más
probable la celebración de una segunda
vuelta entre luis arce ya saben el
candidato del partido del ex presidente
evo morales y el ex mandatario carlos
meza el partido morales sale de una
grave crisis causada por el
derrocamiento del presidente en
noviembre del año pasado un periodo ya
de por sí convulso en el país al que se
sumó encima de la pandemia repasemos
algunas portadas que nos deja la prensa
correo del sur elecciones sube la
tensión invocan a evitar la violencia
diario el alteño incide en esta portada
en ese miedo a brotes de violencia en
bolivia policía y fuerzas armadas en
alerta máxima ante posibles conflictos
los tiempos más el partido de morales
amenaza con convulsión social
ante sospecha de fraude buena portadas
como ven que evocan todas un clima de
tensión y de violencia política verónica
se temen serios brotes de violencia
bueno
sí hay mucha atención actualmente en el
país
yo hablaría incluso no solamente de
polarización sino de antagonismo entre
los candidatos del más y el bloque de
oposición y claro las elecciones llegan
después de un año muy difícil en bolivia
de crisis económica de crisis sanitaria
en el cual muchos sectores muy
vulnerables han sido vapuleados por por
la crisis sanitaria sobre todo el sector
indígena que se es particularmente
vulnerable están geográficamente
situados en lugares donde no hay puestas
sanitarias donde no hay ninguna
infraestructura de salud
y a esto se suma una gestión bastante
deficiente del gobierno de transición
liderado por jeanine áñez con buenos
escándalos de corrupción también ligados
a sobreprecios en la compra de
respiradores de ventiladores entonces
hay un ambiente en el país tenso la
población se siente pues gran parte de
la población se siente pues embaucada
por este gobierno se siente maltratada
por todos estos escándalos de corrupción
asociados a la crisis y además también
por esta postergación de elecciones
sucesivas hace poco ha habido
movilizaciones sociales que pedían que
por favor ya de una vez se diese la se
dieran las elecciones para que se pueda
reanudar con un ciclo
con una gestión a largo plazo que pueda
digamos encauzar un poco la dirección
del país y acotar la crisis económica y
social que existe ahora volvemos a hacer
a poner el foco en bolivia plantes vamos
a hacer un poco fumé en la región si me
lo permiten porque bolivia inaugura un
ciclo electoral inédito para américa
latina luego llegará el plebiscito en
chile y el año entrante un grupo de
países también celebra elecciones la
pregunta es cómo va a influir este
contexto de crisis sanitaria y económica
en el voto de una región tan desigual
como latinoamérica este contexto de
crisis aún va a polarizar más las
sociedades latinoamericanas sabido creo
que eso representa un gran peligro para
el curso electoral que se que se anuncia
para el año 22 2021 porque encima bueno
encima de la pandemia ya tenemos una
situación en américa latina' de
fragmentación de las opiniones de los
votos de polarización del difuso
político ahora
lo que está pasando es que la pandemia
ha golpeado muy fuertemente a todos los
países de américa latina y lo que pasa
es que a pesar de que las medidas
urgentes y necesarias han sido tomadas
por los gobiernos eso no ha ayudado eso
ha empobrecido mucho a la alza a las
personas que trabajan en el sector
informal a toda la clase trabajadora y
entonces lo que pasa es que la gente los
ciudadanos están viendo que no ha
servido que estamos en unas crisis
económicas muy fuertes y el voto en las
opiniones fragmentadas van a
fragmentarse más david van a salir
reforzados los extremismos de todos los
procesos electorales que tenemos por
delante bueno eso lo veremos los
brasileños van a votar para elecciones
locales en pocos días
los chileros van a votar también en el
referendo y en muchos países de la
región hay un clima de enfrentamiento
ideológico ideológico muy muy fuerte y
el y la crisis del cómic no va a
suavizar nada
pero bolivia empieza con este ciclo y es
un test muy importante porque vamos a
ver si este año el proceso electoral va
a poder llegar a un resultado porque
todavía los resultados de 2019 son
inhabilitados y
tenemos que ver si hay un ganador en esa
elección en el primera vuelta o en
segunda vuelta saben si yo puedo añadir
algo en
en el ámbito de américa latina para el
año que viene
yo creo que podrían surgir más líderes
populistas
tengan un discurso como presentándose
como alternativa a lo que han hecho los
gobiernos al fracaso entre comillas
supuesto o real de los gobiernos y eso
es un peligro como lo podemos ver ya en
américa latina' eso esos líderes
populistas que se presentan como una
salvación para el pueblo como si ya
tuviéramos pocos pues nada algunos
algunos más con la pandemia bolivia
volvemos al caso de bolivia en concreto
porque los candidatos lo comentan antes
hay bueno
los candidatos han comprometido en un
principio a respetar lo que salga de las
urnas veronica hay garantías hasta qué
punto existen garantías para los
resultados bueno las garantías que
existen por ahora es primero la palabra
de los candidatos todos se han
comprometido a respetar el resultado que
saliese de las urnas
tenemos un tribunal supremo electoral
completamente renovado a la cabeza del
cual se encuentra un personaje que tiene
índices de credibilidad el salvador
romero ballivián que tiene una larga
trayectoria en procesos electorales
tiene un expertise ya fue
director de la corte nacional electoral
boliviana o seas alguien bastante
comprometido en los procesos
democráticos sin hacer llegar la
posibilidad del voto a lugares muy
recónditos del país muy alejados
geográficamente de esa con dificultades
para acceder al voto y con falta de
infraestructuras entonces por ese lado
tengo entendido que parece que hay un el
tribunal supremo electoral
es una garantizada garantía por otro
lado bueno también están los veedores
internacionales es decir creo que hay
ciertas garantías para pensar que en
nuestro sector a lo que vivimos el año
pasado si a esto se puede añadir la
necesidad también de que todos los
candidatos de todas las fuerzas
políticas llamen a su electorado a
respetar hasta el último minuto el
conteo oficial de resultados que es lo
que desgraciadamente no se hizo el año
pasado no empezaron a haber
declaraciones públicas de la oea de
candidatos mucho antes de que se diese
el resultado oficial entonces esperamos
que todos los candidatos se tengan una
declaración pública en la cual llamen a
sus diferentes bases electorales a
respetar esto es muy importante el
conteo hasta el final de resultados no
sería importante porque si además del
contexto de pandemia nos enrollamos en
otra espiral de violencia y de bueno
puede ser terrorífico para un país como
bolivia realiza ahora mismo los sondeos
muestra un escenario de balotaje el
candidato del partido morales sigue a la
cabeza
un evidente desgaste en el más a qué se
debe ese desgaste y te preguntaría
también luís arce no tiene el carisma
que tenía evo morales y a partir de qué
bueno cuidarse es el arquitecto del
milagro económico y boliviano desde los
13 años de gestión del más él fue
ministro de economía durante los tres
mandatos de evo morales
y es un personaje que puede atraer a la
clase media parte de la clase media
boliviana urbana que votó a evo morales
no son solamente las las clases los
campesinos y la clase obrera boliviana
que votó evo morales
atrae otro electorado centrista
podríamos decir entonces creo que luisa
se es el candidato centrista dentro del
es más que para para permitir una
adhesión se plantea la pregunta al revés
al ser tan centrista luis arce puede
tener más problemas de conexión con
clases populares e indígenas a donde sí
que evo morales llegaba con facilidad
como como comunidad todavía es
presidente el wizard se tiene a david
choquehuanca que es un grado intelectual
aimara
el que el más tiene un vínculo muy
profundo con los sectores indígenas los
sectores campesinos la clave es poder
atraer un electorado más urbano también
y la combinación de david choquehuanca
el wizard se me parece una combinación
para atraer un electorado
diverso y también la clave es segunda
vuelta o no
de mayo los sondeos apuntan a encuestas
que dan wizard second arriba de 40 el 40
por ciento y con 10 puntos de ventaja
sobre carlos meza
en este caso revisarse sería elegido en
primera vuelta y en cualquier si hay
segunda vuelta yo dudo mucho de la
posibilidad del más de volver al poder
porque sería te preguntado si habría una
todas contra el más todos contra el
partido en horario es una especie de
coalición en frente
si yo pienso que no sé lo que puede
pasar pero por lo menos el lado más
derechista de carlos meza y aún más
ultraderechista de camacho lo yo con
personalmente yo lo que temo es que se
salen si sale de las urnas el candidato
mesa que haya una coalición más tarde
entre los todos los lados de la derecha
ese es el escenario que yo tengo y no
bueno no solamente por verlo
personalmente observarlo personalmente
pero hace poco leí un comentario en la
columna de new york times' en español de
un politólogo politólogo boliviano que
dice que se puede acercar en bolivia un
nuevo régimen militar
si es ese tipo de coalición sucediera y
por eso en ese artículo está defendiendo
precisamente el hecho de que gane luís
arce no tanto porque es el match y por
tener un a un lado izquierdista pero
diciendo que arce es trato no es no es
una personalidad como moral es un
populista es una persona más moderada
polarizaría menos ola y salían menos y
que puede conciliar en cuando todos los
aspectos en unos instantes respondemos a
lo que estaba comentando sabin ya vuelta
de pausa también les quiero preguntar la
influencia de la pandemia en estas
elecciones en seria volvemos
[Música]
ah
a
se trata de un conflicto de difícil
solución armenia reivindica el derecho a
la autodeterminación de la población de
nagorno karabaj y la respalda con su
propio ejército mientras que azerbaiyán
considera a karabaj parte de su
territorio y exige la salida de lo que
considera fuerzas de ocupación un
callejón sin salida que intenta resolver
el presidente ruso vladimir putin
convocando aquí en moscú a los ministros
de exteriores de ambas partes
azerbaiyán y armenia con el objetivo de
conseguir por lo menos un alto el fuego
que permita a ambos bandos intercambiar
los cadáveres de los soldados caídos
durante los últimos días que se cuentan
por cientos y también intercambiar
algunos prisioneros de guerra ambas
partes se acusan mutuamente de haber
iniciado esta escalada bélica en la que
están utilizando no solo artillería sino
también aviación y misiles que están
destruyendo muchas zonas civiles a ambos
lados de la línea de combate
[Música]
se empieza a llenar el camino para poner
fin a la guerra de libia los
representantes de los dos gobiernos
rivales han llegado a un nuevo acuerdo
tras las últimas reuniones que han
tenido lugar aquí en marruecos la
delegación del consejo de estado el
senado que es el senado de la parte
oeste del conflicto reconocida por la
onu y la delegación del parlamento de
está brook la parte de este del
conflicto han llegado a un acuerdo sobre
los criterios para la futura asignación
de puestos de soberanía y este acuerdo
llega después de que se celebrará otra
reunión en egipto donde las partes
pactaron una desescalada de la violencia
cabe recordar que libia se encuentra
sumida en el caos y la guerra desde que
en 2011 la otan contribuyera a la
victoria rebelde sobre la dictadura de
gadafi con el tiempo el conflicto se
convirtió en una guerra multinacional
librará a manos de milicias locales y
ejércitos y mercenarios extranjeros
ahora casi una década después se espera
poder unificar las conversaciones de paz
con el reconocimiento de la comunidad
internacional y tratar de empezar a
poner fin a una guerra que ha costado
miles de vidas y que ha obligado a
millones de personas a desplazarse o
refugiarse en otros país
[Música]
cuando estamos a menos de seis meses de
cumplirse diez años de la guerra en
cicla la situación del hambre y la
pobreza se encuentra en su momento más
crítico según la organización mundial de
los alimentos
9.3 millones de sirios se encuentran en
inseguridad alimentaria y 2.2 más
podrían estarlo en los próximos meses
como consecuencia de muchas razones una
de ellas es la crisis económica por la
que atraviesa el país agudizada por las
sanciones impuestas al gobierno la
crisis económica el líbano que es un
pulmón para la economía local y el kobe
19 esto hace que un mercado por ejemplo
valga 23 veces más que costaba antes de
la guerra pero no solamente es una
cuestión económica el hambre y la
pobreza han sido utilizadas como arma de
guerra no solamente por el gobierno sino
también por los grupos rebeldes y
actualmente incluso para muchas
organizaciones internacionales es muy
complicado y hay que negociar mucho
antes de poder entrar estos alimentos y
darlos a la población más vulnerable
[Música]
cubre las historias de la gente con
nuestros reporteros por todo el planeta
nuestros periodistas van donde ocurre la
nutricional
cada semana reporteros le trae una
historia inédita no se lo pierdan
[Música]
acompáñenos en reporteros en cada semana
por france 24 y france 24 puntocom
continuamos aquí en primera plana hoy
analizando las elecciones de bolivia del
próximo 18 de octubre lo hacemos con mis
compañeros periodistas alguien granada a
mí y david gormezano y la politóloga
verónica calvo verónica qué peso tiene
la campaña electoral la gestión de la
pandemia es un tema que es prioritario
bueno
si en la medida que evidentemente está
generando una crisis económica que va a
tener que bate a la cual vamos a tener
que darle una solución no y ha tenido
una influencia en el sentido de que al
ver la gestión tan desastrosa que se ha
hecho de la de la crisis sanitaria por
ejemplo el candidato mes ha adaptado un
poco su discurso de campaña en el
sentido de enfatizar la importancia de
la salud de los cuidados de que el opio
fundamental es que se garantice una
cobertura sanitaria entonces ha
orientado un poco en ese sentido los
discursos de campaña y por el otro lado
es más también lo está orientando un
poco a la necesidad de que vuelva
en el milagroso arce para encauzar el
desarrollo para darle para paliar la
crisis económica se queja mucho de que
le han destrozado sus logros no hay que
tiene que su discurso un poco de campaña
es decir tengo que volver a reencauzar y
haya ya ocuparme de mi obra que la están
las están desmontando entonces por la
crisis económica que ha generado la
pandemia evidentemente está el debate
que se impone un poco ese es ese el
modelo de desarrollo y el modelo social
que se va a generar a partir de él que
va a ser responsable el próximo
presidente luego mucho hemos hablado en
las últimas semanas de las quemas del
programa bolivia se quema qué peso tiene
en este tema en la campaña
en realidad si por algo no destacó yo
creo la gestión de morales fue
presionante por el tema ecológico
que fue un punto débil de la gestión de
evo morales en particular al final de su
último mandato que siempre podrá grabar
de la mano y también
dar a apoyar a unos sectores en el
oriente boliviano que es muy importante
para el maxxi y también para conseguir
la la paz en el país porque el oriente
boliviano siempre fue muy conflictivo
con el gobierno de evo morales y
autorizar que más permitió al gobierno
de morales
acomodarse un poco con los
terratenientes del oriente pero fue en
términos ecológicos fue total
ahora este gobierno interino
pienso erradicar el más del escenario
político con la caída de demoras eso no
sucedió a el tema del código pero que
postergó las elecciones y de una de una
manera reforzó el más y yo creo que este
gobierno interino está en frente de algo
que nunca había previsto que el más está
en posición de volver
al poder a la presidencia gracias a la
crisis económica gracias a la crisis
sanitaria y que se mantuvo un nivel de
institucionalidad después de los eventos
del año pasado con una asamblea
legislativa donde los los miembros desde
el más todavía están y participaron de
una manera en la gestión política
durante este año muy rara pero
el gobierno interino piensa que había un
una vía muy larga que podían presentar
diferentes candidatos porque el más está
fuera del paisaje y no pasó así y no
saben qué es añadir algo más no para no
pasó así pero a la vez hubo un punto
débil en la imagen de él más que fueron
los bloqueos que hicieron hace unos dos
meses creo en los bloqueos de carreteras
impidiendo que llegaran a las ciudades
los respiradores el oxígeno y eso
tuvo una influencia muy negativa sobre
la imagen del más o menos mal que
precisamente después se hayan recuperado
porque hay campaña y que en la campaña
tienen argumentos la presidente interina
jeanine áñez renunció a su candidatura
bueno pues a poco de los comicios para
frenar dice el impulso del más qué
impacto ha tenido esta renuncia en la
campaña a veronica bueno la el hecho de
que jeanine áñez se baje de la carrera
tiene
tiene como principal digamos fenómeno el
arrastre de su voto hacia los candidatos
en mesa y camacho más a mesa que a
camacho y también bueno pues digamos que
hace más bloque no
hace más bloque en la oposición en menos
candidatos se ve más claramente cuál es
cuáles son los que van a llegar los que
los que llegarían con más con más
posibilidades y a los pequeños
candidatos como aquí ya ya ya quiroga
también les roba un poco la salida de
años le roba un poquito de voto a
clarificarse la escena es decir que
éstos este voto que sí que esta
intención de voto que se iba así ya ya
quiroga parece que se va decantando más
hacia hacia los candidatos mesa y
camacho y bueno pues clarifica un poco
la figura no clarifica un poco la
contienda entre quienes se van a dar
entre tres candidatos principalmente y a
partir de todo esto que estamos hablando
y tras un año tan convulso como el que
ha vivido bolivia hay un asunto que no
me gustaría pasar por alto que es el
tema de la desafección de la
desconfianza como ambiente general
instalado en el país no sé esto se palpa
allí esa desafección
no sé me parece que hay una la elección
lleva una atención muy muy fuerte de una
vez
y que la cuestión de los dos es más como
carlos meza como fernando camacho y
pueda aceptar una derrota y creo que
esto es en todas las cabezas que después
de todo lo que pasó sido los dos pueden
reconocer una derrota desde su partido
los analistas ven como probable que en
los comicios se dé el fenómeno del
llamado voto útil como ocurrió en 2019
cuando muchos líderes políticos
convocaron a votar por mesa para evitar
el triunfo del más este escenario es
plausible esta vez
veronica el voto el voto útil sí por
supuesto en claro es llamar a el voto
útil para frenar almas y además mesa ya
lo ha dicho hace creo que fue ayer o
antes de ayer que bueno
tenía pensado a lo mejor proponer
alianzas es decir si el voto útil va a
ser va a ser va a ser muy determinante
si se pasa una segunda vuelta si se pasa
el balotaje y luego está como
reconstruir claro el próximo presidente
tendrá el reto de reconstruir una
sociedad muy polarizada sea el que sea
de los dos va a tener un trabajo por
delante
ingente calidad
sí bueno es
en el camino aunque que va a seguir
bolivia en los próximos meses va a ser
es criticado por toda latinoamérica y
más allá
como volver aún así una normalización
del clima político esto esto lo vamos a
ver y el tema muy clave es es la
economía y el resultado electoral si el
proceso electoral está limpio
transparente y aceptado por
una fracción larga de las fuerzas
políticas en bolivia
eso para permitir un camino político más
fácil por el país en los próximos meses
si el día después de la primera vuelta
nadie está de acuerdo con el proceso
electoral puede ser tremenda entonces
hay un problema que nadie
es añadir si hay algo que se juega que
es fundamental en las elecciones de que
se van a dar ahora es la credibilidad de
las instituciones que es algo que es es
fundamental en una sociedad no que
puedas tener garantías en unas
elecciones limpias pero también bueno lo
que se está viendo es que si arce es el
primer candidato la gente en bolivia la
sociedad le acuerda o sea le da una
importancia a la democracia como
procedimiento pero también le da mucha
importancia a la democracia como en su
concepción sustancial como justicia
social como redistribución entonces es
tan importante que se garantice la
credibilidad de las instituciones como
que el futuro presidente también pueda
generar espacios de representación para
todos los sectores y que pueda
garantizar una justicia social como como
digamos en la mejor tradición del
gobierno anterior digamos de
redistribución del ingreso
con un montón de desafíos a nivel de
desarrollo porque no se puede negar las
preguntas a nivel medioambiental que
existen en bolivia no las quemas las
hidroeléctricas los
la industrialización del litio la
explotación del litro del litio y los
organismos genéticamente modificados
también que están empezando a ingresar
en el país con la soya el modelo
agroindustrial se van a seguir quemando
y plantando en fin hay muchos desafíos
que el gobierno el gobierno de morales
no ha querido ver ha abandonado un poco
la primera promesa de respeto de
medioambiental y de madre tierra
entonces voy a hablar de eso del
gobierno de morales estos últimos
minutos porque dice carlos meza que
cuando evo morales llegó al poder en
2006 hubo desde fuera de bolivia una
imagen disfrazada eiffel de la realidad
del país con un velo de simpatía para el
entonces presidente al inicio de su
mandato lo segundo tenemos ya
suficientes elementos para poder
establecer un legado justo de lo que
hizo y lo que no hizo morales sabin
podemos tener ya propio de los elementos
por lo menos tenemos datos en cuanto a
la economía y al al éxito económico de
de sus de sus mandatos y precisamente
relacionados con la gestión de arse como
ministro de economía es cierto que los
datos indican cultural y cultural de
symbol pero en cuanto a la economía
bolivia logró reducir la pobreza de creo
que a cerca del 30 por ciento de un
tercio y bueno logró un aumento anual de
una atención anual del pib de como 6 a 7
por ciento en lo que no se ve incluso en
la última década
entonces yo creo que tenemos que ver
también el legado en cuanto a él cuando
relacionado cuántos beneficios han
tenido los bolivianos en materia
económica de bienestar de protección de
salud y de políticas nacionales que como
vos decías veronica de redistribución
redistribución de los ingresos pues aquí
lo vamos a dejar muchísimas gracias a
los tres por haberme acompañas en los
que nos quedamos ya sin tiempo estaremos
muy atentos a lo que pasa en bolivia el
18 de octubre y a todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana a quien en primera plana
gracias
[Música]
ah